[Applause]
oh
[Music]
hi
hi i'm mars
the one in the front she looked away
just not her it's not she's not the one
bring it back the one she looked at him
she went um either she knows him but she
already for him and she's like
or her girlfriend knows him or whatever
whatever or not or she's not down with
it just play play that [ __ ] maybe she's
just really into anime
yeah
you know that's not what that's not how
she went
some people have a hard time with eye
contact fair fair i looked at women and
they went
and i don't know if it was because i was
creepy
or because they were shy
and you were creepy possibly
yeah she's doing that before he even
shows up
[Music]
hi
hi i'm mars hey uh i think i think she
bought it about it yeah i think she
looking like i might [ __ ] this thing
i might be wrong i mean to show up in a
pantsuit
she means business
this nigga's mine yeah i feel like i
feel like hey she's dressed like she's
going to work shout out to the sister on
the left 23 i'm from new york you guys
all are beautiful by the way
[Music]
so if you would
swipe right on mars you're gonna stay
if you would swipe left does it know
exit the stage come take a sleep now
hey you know what it is that's the
nicest thing that's ever happened
i get it i get it i get it i get it yeah
that's a nice thing he's super happy
about you know what it is it's like i
used to be there you know what i'm
saying
but now that i made it i get this every
day you know what i mean every girl's
thing
hey
how you doing i'm good how are you
a little bit not news to the attention
not really no oh yeah she means business
yeah oh yo yo yo anytime a girl's like
no no no no no no bro bro bro wow bro
bro bro what a giant beanstalk you got
up there she pissed on him yeah she
pissed on him she was she pissed she
pissed on him that was her territory oh
okay she claimed the [ __ ]
there's something in this video
let me zoom in i want to witness this
urine too yeah
joe she yo she
she claimed that's a move that's a hey
what's that i mean she's already moving
the hairstyle oh yeah even the girl on
the other side maybe she's a little bit
taller but she don't mind
a little bit not loose to the attention
not really
are you a drinker i like to party
sometimes i travel a lot i do uh
modeling they take me places so i'm here
to do some shoots that's awesome do you
have like a model face that you don't
i do not there isn't one most of it is
just like you're talking this girl plays
with her hair one more time listen i'ma
start stroking my dick too okay she's
stroking her head like that
it's on
please don't not literally but you get
what i'm trying to say like in my head
because
and also any got any model
and any model who says they don't have a
model face is straight up camp this gap
that's cat this gap that's kept hold up
how about
this musical as a model face that's the
model he's doing it those are model
faces
bottom right bottom right bottom right
[Music]
we all know what they are
so is there anything you're looking for
in particular like describe your type
okay not to be cliche physically i don't
really have a type you don't have it
bad [ __ ] is the only thing that i
like if you're enjoying today's video
leave a like in a comment right now but
that's lying i swear i promise you
there's three things i look for
hair
lips
and eyes okay classic body parts but
it's like everyone has those oh there's
two things i look for uh oxygen lugs two
legs
what kind of lips what kind of eyes what
kind of hair
like hair what does that really mean
i've seen [ __ ] with no lips
that's why the botox industry in the
lips and gesturing industry is up the
roof it's making money some of y'all
[ __ ] ain't got no lips
and when everything closed down you were
like oh my god oh my god that's why when
the when the lockdown happened a whole
lot of filters start popping up because
you [ __ ] couldn't go
to wherever the [ __ ] you needed to go to
look the way you look
and you guys have tattoos yeah yeah
i do tattoos though would you let me
tattoo you
cool you're crazy i was showing you some
love earlier uh now i'm about to show
you some hate no it's not her it's not
her no not here
that's
it was her
no it wasn't her yes it was did you say
the sister on the right i said the left
oh my bad okay never mind play the tape
back editor no no no i'll play it back
no
shout out to no
sister on the left she's mad for no
reason yeah i don't know
what the [ __ ] what's that
i'm right and i need you to know
i need everyone to know what's your
controversial opinion
oh hi take i think that
people hypothesize too much
people what i'm not about
hype up zendaya too much
he's not lying
he's not lying he listen listen like i
said before i feel like this
every time i look at her head i feel
like she got a tick-tock head i said it
before i say it again every time i see a
movie's in there i don't watch it but i
will concede this because i'm being
charitable okay i did watch euphoria and
i thought she did a good job not my kind
of shop i was like it's actually a
decent but it's not like the whole thing
where everyone's losing their minds but
it was good it was good but what's your
controversial opinion and then they hear
it they're like
that's controversial okay
that's what you asked but you could tell
they all love zander yeah cause they all
look like kids who want to be extras on
euphoria yeah yeah yeah yeah speaking of
before you i watch that [ __ ] bro i ain't
never seen so many dicks in my life they
show dicks only dicks i see a single
[ __ ] the whole time no they're not
gonna show
don't ask me it's like instagram male
nipple woman nipple not the same you're
going to see male nipple you're not
going to see women nipple that [ __ ] was
weird as hell i'm like
flashing dicks everywhere i'm like bro
skip this thing this is weird
it's not weird it's just it's the dick
bruh if i'm not in the locker room i'm
not trying to see that [ __ ] i'm not
trying to see that [ __ ] in the locker
room
but at locker room i accept it because
it's a context i don't go to longer like
that's weird i i don't but
if i'm undercover in my home let's see
flashing detail i'm like no we're not
trying to see that thing but if i'm in
the locker room i can accept it yeah
what do you think is your biggest red
flag oh yeah oh wow okay it's when
someone's rude to waiters and waitresses
yeah
that's a good answer oh he's considered
other people he knows how to act very
good answer and i agree with it 110 100
when i see people but how often do you
see people doing that
you worked in bars
i'm yeah yeah never mind guys on all the
dates i've been on i never seen people
treat like waiters and waitresses like
that yeah not on my dates i've seen
individuals in general but never mind
other than what go ahead i went
this is this this this bar i work at
yeah okay
just the
blessing
there's a girl
that goes there often and she complains
about the food a lot
and the last time i'm like stop ordering
i might i'm like stop ordering you know
i mean and then last time she was there
brad swear to god she ordered a mac and
cheese and didn't want to pay for the
mac and cheese why
because she was lactose intolerant
that is a 100 grounds to dump a girl
100 and she was saying to the girl like
ah sorry like i just learned i was like
was intolerant today and i just flipped
back like i can't eat that yo they're
that's the worst thing on the menu you
could take if you're lactose intolerant
okay and now someone say apple just for
that
you have to imagine
that is
much larger
to go into a restaurant to order food
that you chose and then to afterwards
say i'm lactose intolerant i'm not
trying to pay
you don't care about your social
standing you don't care about how you
look like in public you don't care about
how you treat other people you don't
care about how it makes you look
to me to be involved with you
have i can't take you anywhere
you don't know how to add i've owned who
were you raised by [ __ ] hyenas
what you talking about have ownership
you that was your [ __ ] up that was not
their [ __ ] up like they ask you oh yeah
i'm allergic to i'm allergic to whatever
such and such and there's that that's
that that would be their [ __ ] up that
was entirely a hundred percent
your well you think that people are just
gonna comp you just because you [ __ ]
up no you [ __ ] up pay for that [ __ ] no
no
pay for that [ __ ] but whatever
do you guys feel like he's funny
no no no
hey man well listen models don't have to
be funny no they just have to model they
just have to be
yes put yourself there look at the
camera snap snap it i'm not saying it's
not hard it's a very hard job but you
don't have to be funny yeah i mean their
job is literally to be a prop
yeah
so if you think about it it's to be as
personalityless as possible you're a
coat hanger
now a lot of models are going to get
upset but i mean you're a coat hanger
that look good yeah
well you're a clown
yes
[Music]
so the girls eliminated this round are
kristen and kathy
[Music]
[Music]
i'm a little shy i'm a little shy too oh
that's not gonna work two shot people no
it's like like
two top [ __ ] or two bottom [ __ ]
mm-hmm not gonna work you know i'm shy
i'm shy okay so do you like stuff mm-hmm
[Music]
we'll just off out
you probably can't tell
the first thing i know about you is i
like your outfit oh thank you i chose it
because it was a bit of a power move
i mean to show up in a pantsuit
she means business
and she peed on him i told you she peed
him
hey man and she peed on it ah listen
showing up in a pant suit is a power
movement yeah now i ain't mad at that
yeah everyone showed up with a pantsuit
and she got like a like a like a little
thing showing like skin right
yo i'm seeing that i'm like how you
doing yeah because i'm not even thinking
the pants look sexy but the fact that
you choose to rock that i [ __ ] with it
i think it looks sexy
i think it looks sexy not because
pantsuit looks sexy i think it looks
sexy because of the choice you get what
i'm saying yeah but when they wear it
right with the right person yeah it can
look good they can't be tied to her she
came to win and i think jasmine's gonna
be our winner well
should be your winner but the girls are
going to choose a different man yeah you
play guitar yeah i play piano more
though piano is hard it is so good with
your hands i would say so okay that's
cool that's cool
yeah shout out to cassie she making this
[ __ ] blush i think that's kind of hey
hey that's cassidy that's not kennedy
it is kennedy okay yeah cause i was
thinking of the presidency that [ __ ]
back yeah kennedy play that [ __ ] back
[Laughter]
everybody in the comments let jp know he
got more work that's her editor's name
play that [ __ ] back that's right you
play guitar
yeah
let jp know he got work to do he won't
be able to leave the basement until it's
done no but shout out to kennedy she out
here talking about oh so you good with
your hand
yo she
she like yo run your pockets let me see
them skills [ __ ] what you got
shout out to kennedy she robbie she came
and i was a gang standard she's a
robbing [ __ ] yeah
that's right yeah
you know what's kennedy you wanna know
it's a high note
top of the hood [ __ ] let's go
[Applause]
that's a song by [ __ ] uh what's his
name dreams
yeah whatever
get out get the [ __ ] out
did you who said the dreamcast
that's crazy yeah dream cat whatever the
[ __ ] is he saying dreamcast
oh
do you like to travel i do love to
travel when you said you're adventurous
that's like something i really look for
in a person you know i was thinking
about it before when you said tattooing
to eat you would be done yeah it would
have to be on my face like right here i
don't know i just feel like for it to
really be meaningful yeah it would have
to be on my face okay cool i feel like
that shows i think this is his attempt
at humor yeah he sucks so bad at it that
everyone's like what's wrong with this
guy and she's like oh yeah cool you're
[ __ ] with me what's your ring it is a
chrome hearts ring can i try it on
no
no
if you put it on that finger [ __ ]
what the weather ringer
the wedding finger yeah the wedding ring
what am i saying
[ __ ] the wedding ring
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
roll the thing
okay yeah you have a big finger yeah
yeah
she she didn't put it off she did i knew
i [ __ ] knew it
i'm just gonna say
[ __ ] knew it who's gonna say at 31 i
print
at 23 i would have been like my dick is
so hard right now because we in him this
is the type of girl who likes to please
please yeah
yeah you want that energy she cannot
she
can hold her breath under water for
three minutes
yeah
so how'd you get your name did you like
make it up yourself to mars
do you think i did
i think your friends said okay i'm
actually not going to tell you why
because it's a good secret now i have
something something to talk about i'm
from atlanta i go to morehouse no way
are you kidding do you like it it's cool
better than like new york
oh no no no new york is the best city on
earth la is a close second that's an
opinion yeah it is an opinion but it's a
small one
that's an opinion no i've not i've not
heard that line i like that line i'ma
steal that line mm-hmm that's an opinion
that's an opinion
you know it's it's the equivalent of i
hear you everyone got an [ __ ]
i hear you yeah work that's an opinion
cool
that's what it is yeah that's like
hiking [ __ ] yeah i like that what are
your biggest fears i would probably say
being alone
yeah it's weird though because i'm kind
of sort of a homebody but i'm also
really not
but i'd rather be a homebody not by
myself
completely get you like i like like
watching netflix and like chilling but
with a boot would be great that's
literally telling you oh
i think jasmine is his bae for real for
real
yeah
i'm not going to say i told you so but
you kind of did
but we knew
we knew she came in with that pain too
energy man i could say that
she peed on him and i know all the
leagues watching right now about to buy
themselves some pant suits okay not all
y'all can rock it don't make it look
unnatural nope you know you need a
certain level of like aggressivity or
maybe a hint of desperation you know a
little bit of like i'm coming for it if
you ain't got that in you don't rock the
paint suit did he immediately ask you
questions you sat down and he was like
so he had him ready for you
[Music]
one
two
three
jasmine
what was that
how are you i'm good how are you doing
did you
expect me did i expect you
low-key
low-key low-key did you
expect to be here it was nervous but
maybe
we're done
this is so weird yep i'm not this may be
the weirdest reveal ever you're asking
someone that's not used to talk to talk
that's not what he i get what i mean
because cadence was so whoa
jasmine
you're here that's not how he puts are
you surprised
to be there
bro why are you talking like you lagging
what is that
it's sally's and she could feel the
energy too she'd like to be a little bit
more excited yeah this man is just dead
man
mad man i guess it's a long day it's so
long yes it was nervous but maybe the
suit did something
i'm gonna hand you this oh that's
hilarious and i'm gonna have you reveal
who you were collecting for yourself
[Music]
up you chose violence well
for round two i had
jasmine
ellen and
for the last one
[Applause]
i had
husband
so he's just a weird [ __ ] did you throw
a [ __ ] but shout out shout out to
jubilee because dr was good that was
good that's a good twist you know what
jupiter out of all the daily videos i
think i'm gonna give this one a nine out
of ten y'all they're good yeah they're
good yeah and you could just stop this
dude from having a buffer every 10
seconds that'd been perfect but
otherwise it's amazing
that's funny
i thought you didn't like i thought you
didn't pick me so i was like we're happy
we're ready
you girls are not gonna talk to each
other after that so i mean some of them
might talk like maybe one or two but you
know
um yeah it was funny she was so confused
because she thought she didn't get
picked yeah but i can understand that
yeah shout outs to her though but yeah
shout outs to her
going in for the kill
but anyways that's it for today's video
tell us what you guys think were you
guys agreeing disagree with some of the
stuff we said did you guys enjoy it if
you did make sure make sure you leave it
in the comments yeah yeah
plenty of bad play bad